Blue Beetle scuttles into theaters in
late summer 2023 for those unfamiliar
with the long history DC character we've
got what you need to know before his big
screen debut
fans have been waiting for a Blue Beetle
movie for quite a while at this point
the first whispers about its production
began in 2018. shortly after news broke
that screenwriter Garrett done at
Alcazar had agreed to pen the Blue
Beetle script director Angel Manuel Soto
who garnered attention in a claim for
his 2020 drama Charm City Kings signed
on to the project in 2021. later that
year Cobra Kai star sholo maridueña was
in talks to snag the titular role
principal photography kicked off in May
2022 and filming wrapped up in July
while this steady stream of facts and
figures kept fans satisfied for a while
one particular piece of information
eluded them for months the movie's
release date initially Blue Beetle was
headed for a streaming release on HBO
Max but after some major shake-ups at
Warner Brothers it was revealed that
Blue Beetle would in fact be getting a
theatrical release it will hit theaters
on August 18 2023.
so what's Blue Beetle going to be about
first and foremost it's about Jaime
Reyes when the movie kicks off Jaime's
at Loose Ends he's fresh out of college
and back home in Palmyra City feeling
lost regarding his future things take an
unexpected turn when he's entrusted with
a mysterious package you went in to get
his jobs and all you brought back was
the hamburger
okay I don't think it's a burger a
mysterious alien object known as the
Scarab lurks within its confines and the
shimmering robotic Beetle comes to life
then leaps onto Jaime's face but it
doesn't attack him it bonds with him in
choosing Jaime as its host the symbiotic
Scarab grants him an eye-popping
exoskeleton that spreads over his skin
like water empowered by its alien
technology Jaime becomes the Blue Beetle
capable of wielding an incredible range
of superpowers and weaponry this is
pretty exciting stuff but it's also
seriously dangerous soon after the
Scarab chooses him Jaime finds himself
confronting all manner of adversaries
for mercenary comrade karapaks to
businesswoman Victoria cord luckily
Jaime has his tightly knit Family behind
him with their support he's set to
discover what it means to be an adult a
hero and the legendary Blue Beetle then
closeness of family is something that
makes Jaime different Blue Beetle boasts
a packed cast of famous faces and
exciting up-and-comers sholomar Edwina
star is Jaime Reyes AKA Blue Beetle
Cobra Kai fans will recognize him
immediately as Miguel Diaz Johnny
Lawrence's first student Blue Beetle
won't be maradonia's first time playing
a role adapting a comic book He's lent
his voice to children's cartoons
Cleopatra in space and Big Nate both of
which started his comic book series the
most recognizable names in the Blue
Beetle cast are probably Susan Sarandon
who plays antagonist Victoria cord and
George Lopez who plays Jaime's Uncle
Rudy Sarandon is a Hollywood icon
beloved for her starring turns in movies
like Thelma and Louise Bull Durham
Enchanted and The Witches of Eastwick
meanwhile Lopez is among the most famous
comedians in the world Jaime's family is
rounded out by Adriana Barraza playing
Jaime's grandmother Damian Alcazar
playing his father alpidia Carrillo
playing his mother and bellissa Escobedo
playing his little sister Bruno
marchesina will portray Jenny cord
Jamie's love interest Raul Trujillo
widely acclaimed as an actor dancer
director and choreographer will play the
ruthless mercenary carapax additionally
what we do in the shadows fans will be
pleased to learn that Harvey Guillen is
set to appear as Dr Sanchez the actor is
probably best known as Guillermo the
hapless vampire familiar on the quirky
Effect series you can also expect to
hear the vocal talents of Becky G the
singer and Power Rangers actor as she'll
portrayed Kaji da the voice of the
Scarab that gives Jaime his powers
nice choice director Angel Manuel Soto
is at the helm of Blue Beetle cinephiles
are likely to know him from Charm City
Kings which hit HBO Max in October 2020.
this coming of age drama which is based
on the 2013 documentary 12 O'Clock Boys
follows Mouse a 14 year old kid from
Baltimore Who falls in love with
motorbikes critics adored its
eye-catching cinematography passionate
performances true to life portrayal of
motorbike culture and Vivid Direction
Charm City Kings serves as a powerful
mission statement for Soto which bodes
well for Blue Beetle fans he's
interested in what drives young people
on the brink of something big from their
own glittering Ambitions to their
complex Family Ties just as Jaime Reyes
must balance what his loved ones expect
from him with his own dreams Mouse must
reconcile his love of motorbikes with
his mother's desire to keep him away
from them and the dangers they pose
DC's recent forays into the multiplex
had been complicated to say the least
some movies like Wonder Woman have been
hits but others like suicide squad and
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice went
down his Infamous critical failures
which hamstrung the DC extended Universe
before it got the chance to really get
off the ground the studio has attempted
to address this narrative in a number of
ways but turning to James Gunn has
turned out to be the most successful
after delivering two Bonafide hits in
the suicide squad and Peacemaker the
dynamic director was named co-ceo and
co-chair of DC Studios alongside Peter
Safran now the two are ready to debut
the new DC Universe and as it turns out
Blue Beetle will be its very first
member this is not to say the Blue
Beetle will be the first DCU film as
Gunn clarified on inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum that honor will belong
to Superman Legacy but Jaime Reyes will
be the new universe's very first
character this is a tad bit confusing
but in many ways it makes sense Blue
Beetle is poised to be an ideal bridge
between the tumultuous dce you and the
more classic vibrant and streamlined DCU
Jaime is hard not to like and as a
newbie to the superhero Biz he's an
ideal audience surrogate as far as entry
points go you arguably can't do better
since little is known about gun and
saffron's upcoming Universe of DC
projects other than the titles and the
heroes involved it's anyone's guess as
to where a Blue Beetle might fall on the
official timeline it seems as if the
film could be a part of either the
former DC extended Universe which began
in 2013 with Zack Snyder's Man of Steel
or the upcoming DC Universe launching
with James Gunn's Superman Legacy
in comics there have been three
different Heroes to hold the title of
Blue Beetle and Jaime Reyes is the third
in that line first appearing in 1939 the
same year as Batman the original Blue
Beetle Dan Garrett was the first to
carry the mantle Garrett held the title
until the mid-60s when the second Blue
Beetle Ted cord took over unlike his
predecessor core didn't have a mystical
Scarab to give him superpowers he
invented all of his own crime fighting
equipment including his floating vehicle
nicknamed the bug Jaime became the next
Blue Beetle in 2006 right after cord's
death taking Garrett Scarab and gaining
incredible superpowers from then on DC
Comics promoted the heck out of their
new Blue Beetle advertising and adding
him to just about anything they could to
get the character out there in addition
to being a recurring character in the
Animated Series Batman the Brave and the
Bold and later Young Justice Jaime's
Blue Beetle first appeared in live
action opposite Booster Gold in season
10 of Smallville obviously Jaime is the
main character of the Blue Beetle movie
but some nods and references to both
Garrett and Court have led many to
believe that the other two beat titles
may appear in some capacity at the very
least you can expect the line of
dialogue or two about the former blue
beetles
Blue Beetle takes place in the DC
Universe so the question of whether any
other live-action DC Stars will make
Cameo appearances seems like an obvious
one while we won't know for sure until
the movie comes out it's entirely
possible that other major characters who
haven't previously been Blue Beetle will
also pop their heads in for a moment or
two DC Studios co-head James Gunn has
made it clear that Blue Beetle isn't the
first chronological DCU film in his
highly anticipated Gods and Monsters
initiative but Jaime and his Supporting
Cast could easily be incorporated into
whatever plan's gun and co-head Peter
saffron currently have at a minimum the
Blue Beetle trailer makes Mention Of The
Dark Knight with Jaime's Uncle Rudy
calling out Batman's methods oh it's
like Batman stuff Batman's a fascist
between a Batman mention and the
references to the other blue beetles
it's entirely possible that other
Justice Leaguers might show up by the
end of the flick there were plenty of
secret cameos laced into the Flash and
it isn't exactly a stretch for a
superhero movie to tease a bigger
Universe with Booster Gold being one of
the big projects slated for the upcoming
DCU maybe Blue Beetle will set the stage
for his arrival given how closely the
two heroes are connected in comics
according to reports Blue Beetle began
production in May 2022 around the
Atlanta area specifically the film was
shot at Wilder studios in Decatur
Atlanta is increasingly a hot spot for
shooting big budget movies many of
Marvel Studios features have been shot
there over the years and some of the
most recent DC films including Black
Adam and Shazam Fury of the gods were
shot at least in part in Georgia as well
James Gunn Superman Legacy is also set
to film in Atlanta in 2024 principal
photography for Blue Beetle also
occurred in Puerto Rico and in the
characters comic book hometown of El
Paso Texas in the comics Jaime Reyes
comes from the Border Town of El Paso
where he was first bonded to the Scarab
and learned to be a superhero his
original comic book series which ran
from 2006 until 2009 largely took place
in West Texas and it looks as if the
film is following suit one thing that
always set Jaime apart as a superhero
was his strong commitment to his family
and friends he Reveals His secret
identity to them pretty early on so
filming in the hometown established in
comics makes obvious sense it seems
likely that Jaime's reporting cast will
be continuously involved in his
adventures going forward
unsurprisingly Blue Beetle is based on a
variety of DC comic stories that might
be fun to revisit if you're a fan
according to director Angel Manuel Soto
there are a few in particular that had
some real influence on the production of
the film he said at a press event there
are so many great things from Infinite
Crisis to the new series Blue Beetle
graduation day which actually took a lot
from what we did in the movie The Jaime
Reyes version of Blue Beetle first
appeared in the Infinite Crisis event in
2006. in the series Jaime is recruited
by Booster Gold and Batman to help spot
the Rogue AI brother I because Jaime's
Scarab is the only thing that can see it
their goal is to stop brother I before
it can assimilate all of Earth's
metahumans though released starting in
late 2022 Blue Beetle graduation day as
Soto mentioned actually took inspiration
from the Blue Beetle movie by
incorporating elements such as Jaime's
High School graduation Palmyra City and
Victoria cord into the DC Comics Mythos
it proved that sometimes live-action
media dictates the comics not always the
other way around the director also cited
the video game Injustice 2 as an
inspiration as well as the 2011 New 52
Comics relaunch for the specific design
of Jaime's alien suit
while the trailers have been playing koi
with the exact villains and Blue Beetle
choosing to focus on the relationship
between Jaime and his new Scarab a few
have already been revealed the first is
Victoria Court played by Susan Sarandon
the character was created for the movie
but between the movies filming and
release she has appeared in comics as
the sister of the second Blue Beetle Ted
cord Victoria is after the Scarab for
herself and cord Industries and she
looks to be a formidable opponent for
the newly minted superhero the Scarab
chose you but it belongs to me Raul
trujillo's Kara packs the indestructible
man is apparently also looking to make
trouble for Jaime admittedly carapax
isn't the most recognizable super
villain from the DC Universe but he
originally appeared in the 1980s as a
foil for both Dan Garrett and Ted cord's
incarnations of Blue Beetle again tying
prior versions of Blue Beetle to the
film it's possible that the reach may
also be involved a group of aliens who
initially constructed the Scarab the
reach had been hunting it down ever
since it went missing in the comics this
leads them to El Paso where all hell
breaks loose Bowen confirmed it's
entirely possible that they'll appear in
the film and send their agents to hunt
Jaime down